following last night's golden knights
game in las vegas there were some
questions about tomorrow night's game
with the ducks sports director chris
matthews joins us live in studio with
the very latest details hey there chris
hey kirsten yeah following the game of
course the traditional post game press
conferences where players and coaches
talk about that game well last night
about 15 minutes there the media was
waiting then they were informed there
would not be a press conference
due to covid concerns and then about 40
minutes later the knights released in a
statement saying that today's practice
in media availability
was also postponed we found out today
from the national hockey league that
tomas
nosick was informed he tested positive
for the virus he was taken off the ice
there he is on the right
isolated from the rest of the team so
today he's in isolation per nhl covid
protocols
while the rest of the team continues to
be tested as
of right now the league says thursday's
game with the ducks
is going to be played at seven o'clock
but if there is an issue with tomorrow's
kovid testing among the players
the game could be called off but as of
right now it is scheduled to be played
noschick could be out for a while as it
goes through the nhl's
covid protocols now if the knights do
play they will have alex petrangelo back
in the lineup he
had to deal with covid but he's gone
through the protocols he's back and
ready to go he's been skating
with the team and coach deboer says
yesterday that he will play thursday
so that is good news he's healthy and
ready to continue
knights also made a few moves with the
taxi squad and its ahl club the silver
knights
knight's moving a few players around
tomas jurko
and kayden korzak have been called up to
play with the silver knights while
carl dalstrom and tyrell goldborn will
be part of the golden knights
taxi squad as have right now we'll
certainly keep our ear close to the ice
to see if there are
any late developments